hello my name is Phil welcome to my
YouTube channel amazing troll tips and
tricks in this video I'm going to show
you how to program our first part
this is our first workpiece example
and I'm going to show you how this is a
very simple work piece example I'm going
to show you how to program it from the
beginning to the end
first thing we're going to do is push
the left button and go into program
and then program file
and then we're going to select a work
number that is not listed up here in
order to create a new program
so we're going to select work number 21
so go back to program
push work number
workpiece number 21 input
couldn't find it in the memory so it's
asking if this is a new program push the
program button
and now it's asking us Mesa troll or eia
program we're going to choose a mesotrol
program
work piece material this part is made
out of aluminum so we're going to select
aluminum and a work piece
Max outer diameter of work piece is 3.2
inches
3.25 inches the inner diameter is zero
the work piece length is three inches
long
Max spindle limit this is the G50 for
the entire program I don't want to run
the Chuck past 2000 RPM so I'm going to
type in 2000 and hit input finish
allowance on X this is the stock that's
left by the roughing tools so the Finish
tools can clean it up I'm going to leave
ten thousandths on the diameter so .01
input finish allowance on Z is going to
be
5000.005 input stock removal of work
face I'm not going to have any stock
removal I'm going to skim the part
manually and set the Z zero on this
program
down arrow
first thing we're going to do is turn on
the coolant and that's 99 of the time
what we're going to do for the first
operation so push the three arrows
another menu comes up push M code and
push coolant on and then down arrow
so now we're have another choice of
icons the first thing we're going to do
let's program this part and it's bar
stock so we're going to select the bar
option and we're going to select bar out
the first one the ones that are
highlighted
change the way the roughing tool and
finish tool approaches the part
on the highlighted ones the tool is fed
down into it and feeds across
the ones that are not highlighted are
open Geometry
and the tool Rapids down and feeds
across so we're going to select the open
Geometry
cutting point on X is going to be our
stock diameter of 3.25
cutting point on Z is zero
and what we're talking about is this is
the shape we're going to be programming
The Cutting point is here at the outside
diameter and the face of the part with
medicine troll we always program from
the face and work in toward the chuck
all right
surface speed for rough cut this is what
the roughing tools are going to use
Arrow over surface speed for finish cut
FV and finish velocity this is the fee
speed for the Finish tools feed rate for
revolution for rough cut
and the last one is the depth of cut and
if we Arrow over to the first one this
Auto button pops up if we push it it
auto populates the feeds and speeds from
bar out and with aluminum as our stock
Arrow over
gear number this is the machine's
transmission if we leave gear number
zero the machine will automatically
select the correct gear when it's
roughing and finishing the part
as it is this machine only has one gear
anyway so this field is really not used
on this machine
roughing tool number
this is the tool we're going to use to
rough the part if we push tool data
we're going to use tool four which is a
general out
and it is a 95 degree angle 80 degree
insert
go back to program
or offset number one on this machine
foreign
it has two different offsets offset
column number one and offset column
number two
if we leave the offset at zero it will
not pick up the wear offset
and it just goes by the geometry so we
need to make sure we at least put a one
in there for the wear
finished tool number is tool four offset
number one
so now it's giving us a shape pattern
and we have four different choices for
different geometry of the part we have a
linear which is a horizontal or vertical
line a taper which is an angled line
we have a convex radius and we also have
a concave radius and over here where it
says Center this tells us the center of
the radius when we're programming with
either the convex or the concave radius
when we're
calculating the end point
in this first example we're gonna
create this horizontal line right here
we're going to give it a twenty
thousands Corner break at the front of
the line
foreign
.02 input the final point on x
is going to be two inches in diameter
the final point on Z is going to be 700
thousands from the face
final corner
right here is unspecified so we're going
to leave it blank and use the tools
radius to create that corner
surface finish roughness this is the
surface finish that is left by the
finish tool on this machine
we specify a surface roughness and based
on the inserts radius it'll calculate
the correct it'll calculate the required
surface finish that we want a number
seven is slightly better than a 32
finish so that's what I usually select
for uh 31 000 radius insert the feed
rate will be
.0039 inches per Revolution
the next field is asking us for necking
for an undercut and we're not going to
do that Arrow over the next area is
asking us for an M coat we've already
turned on the coolant throughout the
program so we don't need the M code here
so down arrow
right button figure check
we got the figure left over from when we
board the Jaws so scale
go back to program
right button figure check I turned off
the store so it redrew and rescaled it
for me
I have the store button lit up now we
can see what programming changes we make
to the park so we've got a program
now we need to create the second angle
here
the second feature is an angle so go to
taper
the starting corner is going to be zero
the starting point on X and the starting
point on Z is right where we left off
with the horizontal line
now if we push continue it'll Auto
populate these two Fields down into the
starting point so push continue
now the final point on X for the taper
[Music]
is going to be 2.5 inches the final
point on Z is going to be 1.3 inches
foreign
Corner we're not going to have anything
there
and then surface finishes seven down
arrow right button figure check
and now we can see what we had
previously and we can see the angle
created up there now go back to the
program
go to
we need to create this next horizontal
line
so we're gonna go linear
doesn't have a starting corner on it
2.5 inches is where we left off and it's
1.75 inches back from the face
surface finish is seven
right button figure check
so now we see the program change
each time we've looked at it if we let's
go back to the program
and we need to break the corner up here
another 20 thousandths and in order to
do that we need to create a horizontal
line
that's at least twenty thousandths long
past the previous Z so we go linear
0.02 input this is going to be our stock
size 3.25 input the final point on Z is
going to be twenty thousandths plus two
thousandths so the insert rolls over the
chamfer otherwise it leaves a little
sharp edge on the chamber so that
Dimension is going to be
1.772 input
it's our finish of seven down arrow
shape end
and then we're in we're done with the
program so n right button figure check
so now
if we want to redraw it we push scale
input and that redraws the work piece
and down here on the right hand corner
this is a scale like on a map 0 to 1.7
is shown right now so if you take a
ruler that's 1.7 inches here and it
matches what's on the screen
if we make the scale a smaller number
it'll Zoom this out if we make it a
larger number it'll
it'll Zoom it away
so we want to get more definition of
what's going on so we'll say scale
cursor comes up now we can use our arrow
keys to Center up the
image
change the scale to something smaller
like 0.5 you foot
and now we can see the corner chamfers
on the part
like to really blow it up we're gonna
change the scale one more time scale
move the white cursor box over to the
chamfer
and then type in point one on this
machine point one is the lowest scale
that it goes to
and now we can see the chamfer clearly
on the part
however the rest of the part is off the
screen so we need to shrink the scale
back down and re-center the screen
so scale one input
move the arrow over and I'll go back to
0.6 input
so now we have the image
so
let's go and look at the tool Path
store is lit up so it's going to keep
this scale for us it's a left button
program program program check
and check continue
not done roughing it now the finished
pass is coming up and you see it rolled
the insert over the top
now if you look closely
there's a gap between the purple
geometry and the white tool path the
reason for that is because the white
line is
the inserts tool nose radius
31 000 so that's exactly the distance
the tool is offset
we're done programming the part so now
let's go and touch off the workface and
let's get this run for real
so go to position
go to hand control
and now I'm going to
index to Tool number four
all right tool fours come up and now
we're going to skim the face of the part
so move the turret over to the work
piece
and we're going to skim the face of that
part
all right now that we have the work
piece in we brought the tool up close to
the part
we're going to turn on the spindle
we're going to give it about a thousand
RPM
and then turn it on
I'm over here we're going to skim the
face of the part
foreign
faced off
you can back the X off but leave the Z
right where it's at
now we got to set the work shift
all right now that we've skimmed the
work the work face now we need to set
the
now we need to set the zero so push the
left button go to program
program file
and arrow down to work number 21
Z offset teach
zero input now we go to the left button
and go to position and you notice it's
still on work number 20 which is our jaw
boring program we need to get this on
program 21. so in order to do that we go
to auto go to work number
21 input now it's at zero now we go to
the trace screen
and move the tool and we can see the
tool come into the frame
so let's Zoom it out a little bit so we
can see more of the tool so we'll go to
the right button scale
one input then we'll push shape
so now we can see the Turning tool
now if we want to we can also type we
can also paint the part with the work
piece figure button so when we're
running the Turning tool we can actually
watch simulated stock come off the part
so let's do that here
so that simulates our stock at 3.25
inches and also three inches long
move the tool away from the face of the
part you can see what it's happening on
the screen
all right we're ready to roll
so we're going to go to auto the coolant
button is on
and as a secondary check we are on work
number 21 and we did set the work shift
now let's go and machine the part
thank you
all right our part is done it took one
minute and eight seconds to machine it
on this machine we can simulate the
program actually running without the
machine running by going to program and
go into a simulation screen and then we
can go simulation
ready and simulation start
then we speed up the simulation
a 500 percent
to speed up the graphics but the actual
calculated time
is going to be
close to the same and if we push layout
the total cutting time it calculated is
one minute and 11 seconds
now if we go to the trace screen it
actually ran in one minute and eight
seconds so it was only three seconds off
of its predicted time
and that was our first piece and we're
done with the part
hi my name is Phil welcome to my YouTube
channel mesotrol tips and tricks in this
video we're going to go through our
second demo piece
this is a doorknob or a trailer hitch
ball sample piece
and it's a very simple geometry but
there's a couple of things that we need
to watch for when we're Machining it and
I'll get into that in the video
so let's get started
all right let's get started programming
on this part
this is the part we're working on next
this looks similar to a doorknob
with a sphere on the front of it
the diameter and a chamfer so this is
another easy part to program
so the first thing we're going to do
push the left button go to program
file
and we're going to select a work number
that is not listed up here in order to
create a new program
so we're going to select work number 22.
so let's go to program work number 22
input
and couldn't find it and it's asking if
it's a new program if it is push the
program button
mesotrol or eia again we're always going
with mazatrol work piece material this
is aluminum
Max outer diameter work pieces the same
as the previous program
3.25 inches the ID is zero we don't have
a hole in the stock
the work piece length this part's longer
at 4.5 inches long
Max spindle RPM limit
this is the G50 for the entire program
you don't want to run the Chuck past
2000 RPM
finish allowance on X this is going to
be the Finish allowance with roughing
tools leave for the finishers I'm going
to select ten thousandths which is ten
thousandths on the diameter for x
and then .003 thousandths on Z
because I'm going to be roughing the
tool
with a 55 degree diamond and I want to
leave less stock to the 35 degree
Diamond to finish
stock removal of work face I'm going to
say 0.1 or 100 thousandths
and now the next thing
we're going to do is turn on the coolant
push the three arrows
M code coolant on again that's 99 of the
time we're turning on the coolant it's
the first operation
now we have that excess stock on the
part we need to face it off so we're
going to go with the edge process
and then surface speed for roughing and
finishing depth of the cut again we push
the auto button that auto populates our
feeds and speeds for aluminum based on
the edge process
if we want to kick the feed rate up
and type in a number
.012 input
so now we have 12 000 speed rate for the
rough
we got to be very careful not to type in
0.120
as a hundred and twenty thousands per
rev the machine will not catch that
mistake and it will crash the insert
into the part
been there done that a couple times so
be careful with changing the feed rates
we're going to rough it with tool number
four
input offset always on this machine
offset number one
we're not going to have a finish tool
because it's a sphere and we're going to
finish that with the 35 degree Diamond
so down arrow
starting point on X is the stock
diameter 3.25 input the starting point
on Z at the edge process programs to the
right of zero so we're going to program
starting from a hundred thousands
the work face
final point on x
final point on Z are both zero
and because we have fifty thousand steps
to cut it's going to take two passes to
clean off that face
down arrow
now we're going to start programming
fear and the rest of this part
so we again starting with our stock
and it's an open Geometry so we're going
to go with how
even though this area is closed we're
not starting right here we're starting
over here the tools can wrap it down and
feed into it
cutting point on X again it's going to
be 3.25 our stock size
cutting point on Z is zero
and then we're going to do Auto for the
roughing and finish cuts
[Music]
the roughing tool number
in this program we're going to select a
55 degree Diamond which is tool number
one
and then offset one and then we're also
going to select a 35 degree diamond
for the Finish tool however we're going
to show you a
reason why this can't be done in this
process but I'll get to that in a minute
so we're going to put it in tool two
offset one
so now the first thing we're going to do
is we need to program a convex radius
for this ball shape
and that's this one right here
does not have a starting corner
starting point on X the starting point
on Z are both zero so this is the
xyzero of the program and this is where
we're starting
the final point on x
is going to be this diameter 1.8 inches
and it's going to wrap all the way
around to this line
1.8 the final point on Z is right here
but it's not specified on the print
so we need to do some trigonometry to
calculate that and I'll show you how to
do that with the machine
[Music]
what is the radius of the sphere we're
Machining it's a diameter of 2.5 inches
half of that
is 1.25 inches radius 1.25
and then a surface finish again of seven
we forgot to put a question mark in here
so put a question mark
because we don't know the end point
down arrow
and then we're going to calculate the
center of that
radians so push Center Arc Center X
it's centered on the work piece around
x0 so X is zero
Arc Center Z is the distance from the
end of the part to the center line of
that radius
is 1.25 inches
intersect position a start point we
already know the start point
so we can skip this field
intersect position of final point
we have four choices up here up down
left or right
so what it's asking us is from the
center of this insert where is this
corner located
it's located in the up Direction
but both of these
points on that 1.8 inch diameter are
located up from zero
but this one is located to the left of
zero and this one's located to the right
we want to select the left Arrow so it
calculates this furthest point for us
so left
push the right button go calculate
and it calculated
Z position right there if we go to the
figure check screen
it has the previous
job on here
turn off the scale the store
and go to program
and then figure check and that redraws
the
shape
so now let's hit store
and go back to the program
and now we need to program this
horizontal line here and it has a
starting corner of hundred thousands and
the diameter is 1.8 inches so linear
0.1 push this button and it changes the
hundred thousandths chamfer into a
hundred thousandths radius
1.8 inches
the final point on Z is going to be 3.25
inches from the front of the part and it
has a corner radius of 200 thousandths
at the bottom of the line
3.25
and radius 0.2 input
surface roughness is seven
down arrow
right button finger check
and now the program came across it we
need to break the corner at the top of
the part so we're not done programming
just yet
so let's go back to the program
we need to create another horizontal
line here one hundred thousandths long
so we say linear
0.1 for the chamfer size
this is going to be our stock diameter
3.25 inches and then we need to make the
final point on Z
3.25 plus the hundred thousandths plus
two thousandths to roll the insert up
over the chamfer otherwise it leaves a
little sharp edge on the chamfer
so
3.352 3.352
3.5
2 input
surface finishes seven down arrow shape
in
and then we're end with the program
right button figure check
and we're going to zoom in on the top
half of this part so we're going to say
scale move the arrows toward the center
of the screen would be and then put a
smaller value in here like one
and now we're programming from you can
see the graphics from the center line up
again
this geometry we're not going to be able
to rough out the entire geometry with
the 55 degree Diamond because this end
of the ball is steeper than 30 degrees
but let's show that right now so let's
go to Left button let's go to program
program check
and then check continue
so the first tool
rough some roughs the part off
here's the 55 degree diamond
roughing the nose of the part
[Music]
and now it switches to Tool two which is
a 35 degree diamond and the part's done
however right here it leaves some area
that's not cut an uncut area
even though the 35 degree Diamond can
get in there
the 55 cannot and the finishing tool
will only cut an extra ten thousandths
on X and three thousandths on Z of
whatever the roughing tool left
even though the Finish tool can come
down into it
we're going to zoom this area up scale
0.1 input push shape
[Music]
we're going to center it up a little
closer
[Music]
shape
all right let's run the tool path again
go to check continue
so right now the tools are off the
screen
and we gotta wait a bit until it starts
roughing down the back side of the ball
all right there's the roughing pass and
there's the Finish pass taking off that
ten thousands and three thousandths on Z
but you see the Gap that's shown here
the distance from the center line of the
inserts radius to the part
is larger here than it is over here and
that means the tool could not come down
and cut it so in order to correct that
we're going to separate the roughing and
finishing tools on a different process
so go to program
come down here
go into edit mode
Arrow over to the Finish tool and we're
going to put zeros in there to delete
the Finish tool
copy
the bar out roughing process down
on its own line so we're going to push
the right menu button we're going to go
process copy
two two that's the program we're working
on process number three
and we just copied the process down so
now we need to Arrow over delete the
roughing tool
and add a finish to it
and now we're going to rerun the part
and show you the change so program check
we're going to erase the tool path
and then check continue
and again it's roughing the
nose of the part that we can't see on
the screen right now
all right here's the 55 degree Diamond
making its roughing passes
and the 35 degree Diamond does have the
clearance
and that's what the 55 Diamond could not
do so it's taken extra stock here
on a finish pass so that's how to
override the machine
to
to allow it to do this but I didn't want
to rough the whole part out of the 35
degree diamond
I wanted to rough it out with the 55 and
then this little
uncut area was not a big chip load on
the finishing tool so that's what I
wanted to do there
all right so let's Zoom this out scale
one input
shape
so here's a work piece shape
so what we need to do now is set the Z
zero of our part
so let's go do that now tool four is
already called up
so let's go over and touch the work face
[Music]
all right now we need to set our work
shift so let's bring the tool over to
the face of the part
all right we're
we're gonna take off a 100 000 so that's
plenty close for what we're doing now
so left button program program program
file arrow down to program 22
push Z offset teach and push point one
input that calculated the work shift for
this part so now we go left button again
and go to position
still on the previous program and we
need to call up work number 22. so go to
auto work number
22 input and shows a hundred thousandths
positive on the screen
and now we can see the insert just up
there so let's Zoom this out just a
little bit so one scale 1.5 input
and now we can see the Turning Tool Push
shape and there's our work piece shape
so right button
well let's simulate The Cutting time
first
so let's go to
left button go to program go to
simulation
push the right button simulation ready
simulation start
and our speed is at 500 percent
so now we're going to see the first two
passes with the 80 degree diamond
and then here comes the 55 degree
Diamond roughing apart
and also in the corner you can see our
RPM is maxed out at 2000 RPM for this
program
now it's switched into tool two
and now it's finishing the ball
and finishing the 1.8 inch diameter and
the chamfer
and it's done so let's go to the layout
the machine says it's going to take two
minutes and 44 seconds to machine this
part
so let's see how close that is now that
we're going to machine it for real
so we're going to go Trace
Auto and we did call up the work shift
and we did set the Z zero so we are
ready to roll and the part is sticking
out long enough from the Jaws so we're
not going to hit the Jaws we need to
measure that
just like a different a regular lathe
all right here we go
[Music]
now it's switching to Tool one which is
a 55 degree diamond
foreign
degree Diamond
run the Finish pass
coming up right here where it takes a
little bit extra stocks and
what it should have
all right we are done
time was 2 minutes and 38 seconds
again on the layout screen it said it
was 2 minutes and 44 seconds so it's six
seconds off
time and it on the conservative side so
you can use this to actually estimate
your program
all right
blow the part off
and we are done
and there's our finished work piece
if you like what you see subscribe to
the channel and press the Bell
notification down at the bottom
thanks and keep watching
hi my name is Phil welcome to my YouTube
channel Mesa troll tips and tricks in
this video I'm going to show you how to
machine this part I got right here this
is going to be our third demo piece
and it has turning Drilling and Milling
in it
so let's get started programming this
part
and here's our third part
what it looks like
so the first thing we're going to do
is go to the program screen
the left button go to program
file
and we're going to select a work number
that is not listed up here
so 23 is not up here
so we're going to choose that work
number so go back to program
push work number type in 2 3 input
and it says
program number was not found if it's a
new program push this button it's a push
program
now it's asking us mesotrol or eia and
we're going with Maze of troll on this
work piece material we're going to
choose aluminum
maximum outside diameter work piece is
3.25 inches
minimum diameter work piece is zero it
does not have a hole in it
work piece length is three inches long
Max spindle RPM limit is the G50 for the
entire program
and I don't want to run the Chuck past
2000 RPM so type in 2000
finish allowance on X this is the stock
that the roughers are going to leave for
the finishers to clean up
I'm going to leave ten thousandths on
the diameter so type in .01
finish allowance on Z is five
thousandths
and the stock removal of the workface
this is how much we're facing off the
end of the part
in this case a hundred thousand foot
now the first process we're going to do
is turn on the coolant
for that we need to push these three
arrows
go over here to M code
and then cool it on
and then down arrow
so now the next thing we're going to do
is face off the excess stock on our part
so we're going to push Edge
and then again
the surface speed for rough cut
finish cut and depth of cut we can set
automatically by pushing this button
roughing tool number we're going to use
tool four which is our cnmg
offset one
finish tool is tool four
starting point on X is going to be our
stock size of 3.25 input starting point
on Z is going to be the hundred
thousandths point one
final point on X and final point on Z
are both zero
surface roughness we're going to choose
number seven
what I didn't explain before is the
lower numbers are a much coarser feed
rate and the higher numbers are a finer
feed rate
five six and seven are in the middle
at seven is close to a 32 finish a
little finer than a 32.
so I usually choose that so down arrow
so we Face the ends of the part off
so now what we need to do is describe
this OD line right here
that starts at two inches and it has a
hundred thousandths chamfer at the front
of it
so we're Machining bar stock
we're on the
open Geometry on the outside
cutting point on X is 3.25
cutting point on Z is zero
surface speed for rough cut again the
auto comes up
push that if you wish to override it you
can do that
roughing tool number we're going to stay
with tool four
offset one
finish it with 204 offset one
so now what we need to do is
describe the shape this is going to be
linear
starting corner is going to be the
hundred thousandths point one
final point on X is going to be two
inches
and the final point on Z is going to be
seven hundred thousandths with a hundred
thousands corner at the end of the line
so we push this radius button here first
that changes whatever value I type in
into a radius
and you can see the yellow R Pop Up
surface roughness is seven down arrow
now let's take a look at our shape so
right button figure check
and we've got
the hundred thousands coming off the
face
and then we've got the diameter turned
up to the stock size
if we push the store button we can see
what changes we have from now until
we're done programmed so push store
go back to program
and now we need to make this horizontal
line vertical lines as you saw in this
trait
are done automatically so we need to
focus on the horizontal line
and it has a 2.5 inch diameter with a
hundred thousandths radius at the front
of it
so push linear
push radius
0.1 input
final Planet X is 2.5 input
and the final point on Z is going to be
1.75 inches with a 200 thousandths
radius at the end of the line
radius
0.2 input
surface roughness is seven down arrow
right button figure check
so this kept the image from before and
we can see that we added another linear
line to the program
we're not done with it yet
so let's go back to program
we need to make one more linear line
and that's in order to chamfer this part
right here
so go linear
starting corner is a hundred thousandths
final point on X is going to be our
stock diameter of 3.25
final point on Z is going to be 1.75
plus the hundred thousandths chamfer
plus two thousandths to roll the insert
over the top of the radius if we don't
do that it leaves a little tiny Burr
there
so
1.852 is our finish length
surface roughness is seven down arrow
shape end
right button figure check
now we can see the two chamfers on it
but let's blow this up a little bit to
get more detail
so push the scale button
move the cursors up
and over
and that white box will be the center of
the screen when we change the scale
so let's give it a larger scale of like
one
enter
and that blew it up a little bit
so let's go back to program
so now what we need to do
is we need to punch this hole in the
center of the part
so this is the first menu that comes up
but there's not a drill on the first
menu so we push the three arrows
here's the drill
push that
and the drilling type has four different
selections zero Drilling
feeds in and Feeds out at the same feed
rate and it's useless on this machine
number one packing
feeds in and then Rapids out
to the start
Rapids back in feeds a little more
Rapids back out as a chip clear
number two packing
feeds in Rapids out a little bit and
breaks the chip
and number three reamer feeds in and
then Feeds out at Double the feed rate
most of the time we're going to select
number one packing
drill diameter in this case
it's 0.69
depth of first cut again we got an auto
that comes up
so if we push that it'll Auto populate
our depth the cut our feeds and speeds
so
the first field is the depth of first
cut this is how much it's going to take
when it first enters the work piece
the second one is the decremental depth
to cut this is how much it's going to
minus
off of the depth of cut on each
subsequent pass
and then finally the minimum depth of
cut
for deep holes when this goes down
the minimum depth of cut is going to be
three millimeters or 118 thousandths
surface speed
and the feed rate
the tool we're using is tool 13.
offset one
starting point on Z is going to be the
front of the part
the final point on Z is going to be this
whole depth of 1.57 and that goes to the
end of the hole
on this older machine it does not
compensate
for the drill Point angle the newer
machines
will go down to the major diameter of
the drill past the drill point on this
one it does not
so type in 1.57 input down arrow
and then right button figure check
and now we've got a hole punched in the
part again you can see there is no angle
shown
on the hole
go back to program
so now what we need to do is describe
this
bore size
the bore it's a 900 000 Spore
with the one hundred thousands chamfer
at the front of it
so again we're using bar stock
in this time and it's still open
Geometry
cutting point on X is going to be our
drill diameter 0.69
cutting point on Z is zero
again surface speed for roughing we push
Auto and it auto populates our feeds and
speeds for us
roughing tool number is tool 12 offset
one
finish tool is tool 12 offset one
so the next thing we're going to do is
the linear
starting quarter is a hundred
thousandths
final point on X is 900
the final point on Z is going to be 1.3
inches
and the final corner I forgot to put on
the print is a 50 000 radius at the
bottom of the hole so push radius
0.05 input
surface roughness is seven
down arrow
and now let's chamfer the hole going
into the drill so go linear
let's give it a twenty thousandths
chamfer
0.69 for the hole size
and then we gotta go
this Dimension 1.3 plus 20 thousandths
plus two thousandths to roll that
insert over the chamfer so
1.322 input
seven down arrow shape in
and then end
I haven't touched on the end
process in the machine yet but this is
very powerful when you need to do
multiple parts
or switch between programs and Etc it's
very useful for bar pulley on this
process we just need to push and and
leave everything zero
so let's go to the right button figure
check
and there's our board
so now let's look at the tool path
so left button
go to program that gets us out of edit
mode push check
and then check continue
so what it's going to do is it's going
to rough the face
and it's going to finish the face
and it's going to rough the OD
tool path that race to erase what the
graphics
here's the finished OD pass
now it's going to drill the hole in the
center
it's going to rough the bore
full path of race
and now it's finishing the board
so this is how it's programmed but this
is really not how I want to run this
part I would like to rough out the part
and then run the Finish tools
so I'll show you how to do that now so
go to layout
and if you notice it's got R1 which is
the coolant
R2
is The Edge process this is the roughing
process
and then the Finish process
and so on Down the Line
now if we push rough priority on this
screen
and then push the input button
notice how it reorganizes
all roughing processes up front and then
finish processes at the end
and
this is fine for how it's programmed but
to eliminate one tool change
I want to move this finish
bar in process above
the finished turning process
so to do that move your arrows down
and it's going to insert a line above
where the cursor is
so go move
process to insert it's going to be a
finished process
number five
input
and now if you look
we're roughing it with tool four
drilling it with 13.
roughing it with tool 12 finishing the
tool 12 and then come back with the cool
forward to finish the face and finish
the OD
D you got to be careful on this screen
because you can actually put the Finish
tools above the roughing tools and crash
the part
so when you play with the layout you got
to be wary of that issue the newer
machines have a protection against that
on this one because you're doing it
manually it'll allow you to do that
so let's go back to the program check
cool path of race
and then check continue
now it's rough in the outside
now it's changing tools to drill it
rough the bore
to a path of race
finish the board
finish the face
and now finish the OD of the profile and
it's done
so now from here
what we need to do is set the workship
so we're going to come over and set the
Z zero for this program
[Music]
all right we're ready to set the work
ship so come over here to manual
come over to the face of the park
and let's turn the spindle on
the 300 RPM
there we go
[Music]
all right we're touching the face and we
easily cut off a hundred thousands
so stop the spindle
come over here and go to program
go to program file
arrow down
Arrow over to the Z offset we're going
to teach it so push Z offset teach
point one or a hundred thousandths in
front of our zero because this is the
rough stock we're Machining off get
input
and now we've taught Z so now let's go
to
the position screen
and we're in program number one right
now so that's why the Z
is not at a hundred thousands so push
Auto
push work number
23 input
and now we're at a hundred thousandths
we
on the edit On The Run side we're on
program 23.
so let's go to the trace screen so left
button Trace
and now we can see our turning tool
just like it is on the part
so now what we need to do is go to auto
turn on the coolant in Auto not in
manual
and then let's sit cycle start and run
this part
[Applause]
making this two roughing passes
all right
[Music]
now comes the drill
and we're done drilling the part
bring up the boring bar
[Applause]
all right done roughing it now it's the
finished pass of the boring bar
now it's going to come up with tool four
[Music]
so right now it's cutting a little bit
of air
before it cuts the part in later videos
I'll show you how to I'll show you a
trick to get rid of that
for this video
it's fine
foreign
all right now in this case I want to
show you guys how to rerun a process
in order to dial in the
the fart
so let's say the OD was 2 000 bigger
than it should have been
first thing we're going to do is going
to go to the wear screen
so we're going to push the left button
go tool set
and then we're going to arrow down
to wear offset number one
in X and we're going to go minus
.002 input
so this is going to take two thousandths
off on the diameter
on 204.
so now what we need to do is go back
and let's go to the
program
to the layout screen
and we want to run
the last process the F3 the Finish three
process
so what we're going to do is going to
push this button down here single
process
the position
and it's asking us which process do you
want to run
we're going to push finish
three input
and then we're gonna
we can do the same thing on the trace
screen
so finish three input
there's the coolant
now let's close the door
and let's
hit cycle start
and one thing to note it says
2.498 on that diameter
on this machine and on every maze act
that I've come across
the wear shows up in the geometry when
you're running the part some people
found that annoying but it's a nature of
the maze Act
you can actually see
there's a where
going on because it does adjust the
geometry
all right and we are done
we check it
check the size if we like it or we can
rerun it again
but that's how to re-run a finish pass
using mesotrol
so we are done with the part
blow it off
and that's our
our finished part
good
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe
also push the note of the Bell
notification
to be notified when we get new videos
coming out
thanks and keep watching